As a child you might have wondered how a bowl
of punch could be pleased about anything.
Turns out, the saying has nothing to do with
the drink.
Rather, “punch” refers to the character
in Punch and Judy, a puppet show that has
its roots in Italy’s 16th-century commedia
dell’arte.
By the 17th century, the show had spread to
England.
The first known record of the English Punch
and Judy appears in the journal of Samuel
Pepys, who saw the show on May 9, 1662 in
Covent Garden, London.
He wrote,
Thence to see an Italian puppet play that
is within the rayles there, which is very
pretty, the best that ever I saw, and great
resort of gallants.
The show continued to gain popularity and,
by Victorian times, was being played in all
of the major cities in England.
Today, Punch and Judy is still performed,
though it is much more popular in the UK and
Europe than it is across the pond.
If you’re unfamiliar with the show, you
might be wondering what it’s all about.
It’s a sort of “variety” puppet show
that acts as a living history—the show is
always kept topical, which is a major reason
why it has remained so popular over the years.
No two shows are exactly alike.
Instead, they stay true to the issues of the
time, often mocking current political leaders.
For instance, Hitler was once featured in
the show, and more recently, former British
Prime Minister Tony Blair made an appearance.
But the main man of the show is, of course,
Punch.
Usually portrayed as a “hook-nosed, hump-backed
buffoon,” Punch is considered a somewhat
politically incorrect character to put it
lightly.
He has been depicted beating his wife, murdering
people, and performing other unlawful, mischievous
acts.
Yes—a sadistic, evil, serial killer puppet
gave us the saying “pleased as Punch.”
So, how exactly is he “pleased” again?
Punch is always gleeful about the mayhem he
produces, and appears to be self-satisfied
by committing heinous crimes.
The first time the exact phrase, “pleased
as Punch”, was recorded was sometime in
1797.
The phrase showed up in The Baviad, and Maeviad,
satires by William Gifford:
Oh!
how my fingers itch to pull thy nose!
As pleased as Punch, I’d hold it in my gripe.
That said, it used to be that “proud as
punch” was another phrase used as commonly
as “pleased.”
You can find an instance of this in Charles
Dickens’ works.
For instance, in the 1850 publication of David
Copperfield, he wrote:
I am as proud as Punch to think that I once
had the honour of being connected with your
family.
Four years later, in Hard Times, Dickens wrote:
“When Sissy got into the school here…
her father was as pleased as Punch.”
Today, “pleased as punch” is the much
more common phrase, while “proud as punch”
has faded into the background.
It’s funny to think that we owe it all to
a wife-beating, serial killer puppet—but
the phrase certainly makes more sense when
you know it isn’t attributed to
the stuff in your punch bowl.